and we are now just two days away from
the grand opening of resorts world the
newest property on the las vegas strip
we've been
talking about the big name residencies
all the amenities they're going to have
there
but there's also a lot of excitement
about its convention space
oracle mana joining us now live near
resorts world with a closer look at that
orca
well denise we all know that conventions
and events are a crucial part of las
vegas economy
and with resorts world's amount of
meeting space
and location on the strip local
businesses are optimistic about the
opportunities here
we're certainly embracing them gallery
owner tony carnivale
is ready for resorts world to open not
only for its glitz and glam but also for
the event space
extremely exciting for me carnivale
hosts art shows with pieces like these
and with more than 250 thousand square
feet of event space
resorts world is the perfect place to
capitalize on a different clientele
there'll be a new crowd of people new
attraction new people will be coming to
see it
love the opportunity to showcase my work
there take it one step further and
resorts world is poised to be a new hub
in las vegas convention industry
michelle tell who reads tarot cards and
caters cocktails during convention
says this is good news the more
businesses that come in the more trade
shows the more we get hired as local
companies
it really does feed into the local
economy it's also a stone's throw away
from the convention center expansion but
can a new resort break into the
convention marketplace
i think in the short term there will be
a lot of competitions i think they need
to make a compelling case to groups
they're a good place to have a meeting
but there will eventually be room for
everyone
many of these conventions are big right
they are bigger than one facility
having additional space allows them to
have city-wide
activation and local businesses are
prepared if there's an opportunity there
in particular i'd love to jump on it
resorts world also has six ballrooms
which we know
can double as space for exhibitors
guests will finally get a glimpse of
that space
and the rest of the property once it
opens its doors
finally for the very first time this
thursday night reporting live near
resorts world tonight
orca mana 8 news now